I'm Lauren Ginsburg professor of ancient
Rome and I'm here to answer your
questions from the internet this is
ancient Rome
[Music]
support at ABA Eagle why did Romans wear
toas the average Roman did not go out of
their house hanging out in a toga
because toas were extremely long
extremely complicated gowns to put
together so even extremely Elite Roman
citizens recognize the toga as a
ceremonial gown I like this image
because we have all these people who
wearing things that are decidedly not
toas what they are wearing is the basic
Roman garment that anyone of any status
male or female would wear which is
What's called the tunic or the Tunica
and this is essentially a long t-shirt
at c450 HS did the Romans really wash
their clothes in urine yes and
essentially so do we so if you look at
any of your household cleaners you will
see that one of the highest ingredients
generally is ammonia it's very costic so
it's not always very good for your
things but but it cleans extremely
effectively and so the Romans were able
to recognize that urine when stored for
quite some time tends to break down into
ammonia so when you would bring your
clothes to um a fonica so this is a a
laundromat essentially in the ancient
world the first thing was it would go
into a vat in which highly concentrated
urine would be poured and you would let
it sit there then the clothes would be
washed with clean flowing water in three
to four separate Vats until the end it
was basically perfectly clean and it
could be line dried Finn Huck did the
Romans really have vomitoriums yes but
not in the way that you mean it is true
that if you look at some Urban plans in
Rome Stadium buildings amphitheaters
theaters places where tens of thousands
of people would come you will often find
the word vomitorium that's written there
and somehow a myth has been created that
this is where decadent Romans would go
after they ate too much food and they
would Purge themselves this is not what
those words mean it comes from the Latin
word vomo vay which basically means to
send forth and so yes on the one hand
send forth your food but on the other it
can mean to send forth people so what
these were were actually large large
stairways to get lots of people out of a
stadium very quickly so we actually
still use the exact same technology that
Romans called vomitoria we just don't
call them vomitoriums and I for one
think maybe we should at not landl man
they didn't even have popcorn back in
ancient Rome true story what did they
snack on in the Coliseum this made
headlines last summer because they've
actually started to do excavations in
the drainage system of the Coliseum and
in the sewers because if you think about
it if you go to a rock concert today you
can see everything sticky on the floor
people throw their food all over the
place where does that go in ancient Rome
it would go down into the drains and it
would go down into the sewers and that
means that things that can survive for
those Millennia we can be able to tell
that those were the kind of foods that
were snacked on all sorts of varieties
of nuts and residues of nuts have been
found in these sewers fruits for example
figs and peaches and other fruits grapes
that were easy to carry also what they
discovered was that people seem to bring
or at least have access to small
portable grills sort of like tailgating
grills little brazers where they could
grill meat at the time as you watched
people fight to the death and animals
die at jwad dog why does concrete from
ancient Rome stand up better than modern
concrete if we look at this dome in the
pantheon of Rome it looks pretty
spectacular today if we consider that
this Dome is made of concrete and we
think of a bridge that might have been
built in your city in the 1970s these
two things do not look the same so just
this past summer a team of civil
engineers from MIT set out to figure out
what this was and they think that they
have an answer if you look at Roman
concrete you can see in The Matrix these
chunks of white material so this group
of MIT scientists figured out that these
white chunks called lime classs were
deliberate and were also proof that the
Romans used something called quick lime
as opposed to Lime that had been
premixed with water which had always
been the Assumption and that quick clme
superheats the chemical process as it
makes concrete and so one of the things
we've always known about Roman concrete
is that it can Harden really quickly
including underwater also the other
property that they were able to recreate
in the lab was that Roman concrete can
be self-healing to a certain amount so
if you put modern concrete and Roman
Concrete in a stress environment so that
the concrete cracks Roman concrete can
actually heal that cracks and the key
that they think they found is that these
lime clasts these calcif aized white s
would be able to immediately distribute
material to those cracks and help with
the self-healing properties it is much
more expensive to make concrete this way
so I'm not actually sure that we're
about to have a Roman concrete
Revolution but it is pretty cool that
these scientists think they've recreated
what the secret of Roman concrete is at
Dylan's fault did those Gladiators
really fight lions how often did they
die absolutely Gladiators really fought
Lions it's not even like they would just
be released from a gate and everyone
could tell and Architectural
investigation has shown the technology
through which Lions below the surface of
the floor of the Coliseum would able to
be launched into the air to suddenly
appear but the question about how often
did they die we have tombstones that
show Gladiators who have won um 50
different competitions in their life
evidence of Gladiators who retire from
being a gladiator and train other
Gladiators and so it wouldn't really
make sense if every time they went into
the arena there was a 50-50 shot that
they weren't going to walk out instead
what we see mostly when it's human
versus human Gladiator versus Gladiator
is a heavily stage managed choreographed
fight that's designed to be extremely
exciting for the audience that doesn't
mean that they weren't sometimes killed
we do also have evidence that Gladiators
could be killed but that would have been
agreed upon in advance by whoever was
running the games and whoever had
nominal control over the gladiator's
life we have get Gators what did the
Romans invent that we still use today
one thing we want to poke at is this
word invention because the Romans sort
of took things that existed concrete is
a good example and perfected it but the
example I think of immediately is
actually surgical tools scalpel tweezers
forceps but the actual basic tools if
you looked on say the set of gry's
anatomy or some medical show would look
extremely similar to what the Romans
were using in the past and they would be
made out of similar types of metal from
this is Nico did they have bars in
Ancient Rome or did wine just flow
freely down the streets unfortunately no
but they did have bars and they had bars
all over the place so these were often
called TNI and these would be bars where
you could get drink but you could also
get food and this is a great example so
this comes from some recent excavations
in Pompei in an area that were just open
to the public and what you can see here
is a big counter so you could imagine
someone behind here actually serving
alcohol but those big jars that you see
would also have food so stews Rich hot
items that people would either get to
have as their primary meal of the day in
the bar or that they would then take
home where they could heat it up simply
so these bars show up so often in these
workingclass neighborhoods of Pompei and
the analogy I like to use is they show
up as often as a Dunkin Donuts does in
the city of Boston and the graffiti that
we found on them shows that they're
really a Social Hub of the neighborhood
it's likely that you would just go to
the pub on the corner much the way we
think of neighborhood bars today from
attemps Flame come on I suppose next
you're going to tell me that all those
Greek and Roman statues were actually
Godly painted yes I'm here to tell you
that all of those Greek and Roman
statues were painted but I object to the
term Godly when people think about what
it was like to walk around the streets
of ancient Rome they think about these
things that are here bright white Marble
Marble buildings marble statues the
Romans would have found all of this
white marble extremely boring they loved
vibrancy and they were also worldclass
painters there was a fantastic exhibit
last summer at the Metropolitan Museum
of Art that actually featured a number
of recreated statues in which scientists
had very carefully taken tiny bits of
pigment on statues so you could see that
say a statue of someone like Nero here
each layer of clothing would be painted
with shades with texture with patterns
and the same thing is true with Roman
buildings Rome was a wash of color
Nevada D Knight 67 was ancient Rome
really a sexual free for-all so here's
the thing Romans had a very healthy sex
life Romans had sex inside and outside
the institution of marriage Romans had
sex for procreation yes but also for
pleasure Romans had access to
contraception Romans especially Roman
women would rise up when they thought
that those rights were being curtailed
Romans have pictures and works of art
and uh literary texts that talk about
sexual desire the talk about sex acts
the talk about their favorite positions
short it's Woman On Top is the thing
that they seem to like a lot men have
sex with women men have sex with men
women have sex with women women have sex
with men and so much like today it was
really a spectrum of sexual behavior
sexual performance sexual interest from
The Kino Corner which Roman Emperor was
objectively the best the Roman Empire
was an autocracy which means that all
Roman emperors were autocrats and it
means I don't actually think any of them
were very good people I think in general
that form of government doesn't lead to
people doing good things so I'm going to
take a couple of examples of good and
bad Emperors we have a friend Nero here
who everyone probably agrees the worst
of the worst Emperors and then we have
everyone's favorite Emperor on the
internet Marcus aelius he wrote this
nice book of stoic philosophy and so
people think he's extremely chill and
thus under his Empire things must have
gone particularly well but let's ask
this question objectively the best for
whom and was he objectively the best for
the uh substantial population of the
Roman Empire at that time who were
enslaved we always have an idea of what
we mean as best for whom and I just
don't happen to think that the Roman
Empire produced anyone that we would
consider to be a fair ruler today at
royally Ari how often do you think about
the Roman Empire well this is a little
bit of an unfair question because I have
to say the answer is more than daily
because it is a professional oblig ation
I probably think about the Roman Empire
more than your average person anzora HQ
how effective were public toilets and
bathrooms at keeping people clean and
how was hygiene in ancient Rome Romans
had extremely Advanced Technologies of
water for example they had extensive
systems of aqueducts that were able to
bring clean water across vast expanses
of land they had a sewer system as of I
believe the 4th Century BC that's
bananas they had public bathing
facilities so it was very regular if you
were a Roman no matter your status to
actually go and use these bats on a
daily basis to clean yourselves and yes
they also had public toilets this would
not be the only place that people would
go to the bathroom but you can see in
this that we would have stalls they
would probably not lead to a lot of
privacy and you can see that running
along down the side of them would be
places for channels of water so what
were the Romans not good at in terms of
hygiene with this water technology well
they didn't understand things like
dissenter about communicable diseases
that way and so if you're having um say
reusable toilet paper which in the Roman
world would be a sea sponge and it's
being cleaned in vinegar which can do
some things that's not going to stop
things like dissenter from being passed
along anzora HQ what kind of toys did
Roman children play with we have so much
wonderful information about the value
that was put on playing as a social
emotional strategy for raising Roman
children one of my favorite is actually
this doll this particular one is made
out of Ivory and what's so impressive
about it is you can see that the limbs
are articulated so you can see that you
can sit this doll down you can have her
stand up and this doll actually also has
the famous hairstyle of the Roman
Empress at the time Julia DNA so she's
also a high fashioned doll we know that
dice games were very common walking toys
that would clearly teach little toddlers
how to walk and a lot of the building
blocks that teach children how to play
with each other were considered
particularly important and with this
doll could also be considered extremely
beloved objects that someone would keep
well past their girlhood from El Gringo
Loco what was the average lifespan of a
Roman peasant this is a really great
question because you're going to find on
the internet when you look this up this
idea that the Roman average lifespan was
35 years and then people often think as
a result that if you made it to 35 you
were grandparent age and that's just not
true cuz we have to think about what an
average means infant mortality in Rome
was astronomically High most children
died within the first year of birth so
that was just infant mortality child
mortality about 50% of children died by
age 10 and you can see already why
that's lowering and lowering that
average so if you made it to age 10 as a
lower class Roman citizen whether you
were living in the country you had a
decently High chance of making it into
your mid-50s and we know plenty of
people lived beyond that our next
question is from Christa Colin how does
an archaeologist look at an ancient
column and conclude this was a Roman
brothel they could not do that we do
know that there's a very famous
purpose-built brothel in Pompei the
building is entirely full of tiny stalls
and in each of the Stalls is only a
bedshaped platform above the Stalls are
extremely graphic sex acts and then
there is graffiti and my favorite that
has survived is over one stall and I
have to imagine this was from the sex
worker that wrote thrust slowly putting
all of those things together it's pretty
easy to see that this was a place where
sex work was on the agenda namona TWU
what rights did Roman women gain in
Imperial Rome Roman women couldn't vote
and that's a big one but Roman women
could be citizens Roman women could own
property in their own name they could
inherit property in their own name Roman
women could be business owners and some
of whom were using their own business
sense to advance their children
especially their sons and their
political ambition Roman women could
hire a lawyer to defend themselves or to
bring a suit in court Roman women lived
with a greater degree of Freedom across
social classes than we're used to seeing
in the ancient world at in cream cakes
how many civil wars did Rome have
including the Byzantine era that is a
very hard question to answer um for very
good reasons one is that the Romans
thought that Civil War was something
inside them that you had to fight
against every day or it would erupt
Romans had documented Civil Wars and
they're the ones that actually came up
with this term where two Roman armies
would fight each other headed by two
Romans but what's the difference between
that and an uprising of enslaved people
who are part of the Roman population
like Spartacus is that a civil war
what's the difference between the whole
system of Roman provinces rising up
against Roman rule they're part of Rome
and they're rising up and they're
fighting but they're fighting more with
Gorilla War tactics do we call that a
civil war you can see it becomes very
hard to parse when one part of Rome is
fighting the other but it happens all
the time at blood orange what the
did ancient Romans wear during the
winter I know right cuz all the images
we see are in these sort of lightweight
linen shirts and like sandals that's our
image of Rome and it's snowed in Rome
well the key to Roman happiness in this
would be layers in the same way that it
is today and Romans actually had access
even then to material that we know is
the best to keep you warm and that is
wool so the average Roman would wear
socks yes Romans really pioneered the
idea of socks and sandals they would
wear extra thick socks but they also
didn't just wear sandals they had thick
leather shoes and the more layers of
leather the better those shoes would be
in Winter conditions and then cloaks
tons and tons of beautiful wool cloaks
on top at Robert Smith 29th I was
wondering how the Romans produced their
Roman coins and how they put the emperor
onto the coins the way the Romans made
coins was a by-and process so what you
would do is you would have a base and
you would put in this base a mold that
had one side of the coin and in that
mold you would put a metal disc and I
would put it face down so you can
imagine it's almost like a clam with two
molds and the metal disc goes in here
then I take a hammer and I whack it and
that's called stamping and that would
put the images on both sides of the coin
from at theist and thought did ancient
Romans go on Hikes or go to the beach
for relaxation yes there was a heavy
Leisure Time activity in Rome where
people would go to the coast especially
the Bay of Naples and have Seaside
Villas and go to these really fancy
baths sort of like a spa vacation but it
could last months the extreme Elite of
Rome that would have access to these
Seaside Villas so the average Roman
person probably didn't have a lot of
time to be able to do that so what did
they do to relax Rome had a lot of
holidays around a festival calendar and
these festivals would feature
gladiatorial matches they would feature
Chariot racing they would feature um
theatrical spectacles including the
ancient equivalent of musicals and we
have evidence that people even from
rural communities would come in for
these festivals especially the big ones
that's because they were state holidays
in the Empire there were over 100 days
of public holidays at just tamon so like
in ancient Rome what was living there
like people worked and then went home
and did they pay rent the average Marcus
I should say instead of the average
Average Joe he could be a shoem maker
could be someone who sews clothing could
be a launderer any of the activities
that you need done in your general city
life would be the same thing that they
would need done in ancient Rome
sometimes home was right above you if
they were quite wealthy they might own
the space that their shop is in but
often they would be renting out both of
those spaces from a landlord and you bet
the Romans complained about their
landlords shotty upgrades Vermin that
weren't being taken care of a neighbor
who parties too hard and wakes the baby
at tweak fan 25 did they have weed in
ancient Rome yes but not in the way that
you are asking Romans really loved hemp
as a plant and they loved how easy it
was to make ropes with it we find hemp
products all over the place and hemp the
word for it in Latin is cannabis so you
can see the connection but there's no
sense that the Romans first of all
smoked it smoking was not a particularly
good thing in Roman culture but there's
also not great evidence that they
recognized it sort of mind-altering
possibilities at Kevin feny it will
always be faintly extraordinary to me
that Roman historians cannot agree on
the answer to the superficially simple
question of how many Roman emperors were
there so when Augustus is the first
emperor he declares a successor tiberias
tiberias becomes the next Emperor and
miraculously we have two so why is it so
hard to keep counting eventually Rome
becomes big and eventually other people
decide they could be Emperor and what
does it take to become emperor for a lot
of Romans the answer is an army that
they're paying can declare them Emperor
and they can besiege Rome until they are
declared Emperor flash forward to later
in the Rome Empire when we have divided
centers is the center of Rome the city
of Rome anymore no there is a center in
Constantinople and sometimes it's Milan
sometimes it's Rena we're getting then
multiple Emperors or people who could be
perceived as Emperors at the same time
but we also get usurpers guys with
armies that come in think I could do
this and who gets to declare them
Emperor at that point there aren't rules
for this one way or another it can
become really hard for us to tell who is
Emperor and sometimes all we have is a
single coin as evidence just one coin
that one guy who claims to be Emperor
minted was he Emperor we have no idea at
terara encounters how many gods did
ancient Romans worship it's not really
fair to ask how many gods they worshiped
it's more fair to ask what gods didn't
they worship Romans saw Divine in lots
of things Springs had a Divine being
caves had a Divine being they had a
festival to ward off mildew and it was
called the Ralia and it was in April and
that showed that they also thought that
Milo had a Divine spirit in it that they
could essentially bribe to not destroy
their crops so the Romans had a really
heavy investment in seeing the Divine in
as many places as possible and finding a
way to connect with that religiously at
shakes Shure I need someone to tell me
if ramulus and Remis were real like
immediately ramulus and Remis are the
legendary founders of Rome they were
twins who'd been expelled from their
patrimony by an evil King and they were
supposed to be drowned in a river and
the legend goes that a She Wolf found
them and nursed them and prevented them
from dying and then when they grew up
they were able to overthrow the evil
King and they were able to found their
own civilization but even the Romans are
pretty skeptical about this story you
can see a lot of the historians later
saying really a She Wolf are we sure it
wasn't a sex worker that we just called
a She Wolf this was a pretty legendary
story sort of like George Washington and
the cherry tree and they didn't put much
factual Faith behind it all right that's
all the time we have for questions for
today I hope you learned something weird
and interesting about Romans and we'll
see you next
[Music]
time